Speaker 1: Let's now get to defining woke.
Here is Nikki Haley also running for the 2022.
2024 presidential Republican presidential
nomination.
She got herself a nice little CNN town hall.
She was asked to define woke.
It did not go well defined woke.
Speaker 3: There's a lot of things.
I mean, you want to start with biological
boys playing in girls sports.
That's one thing.
The fact that we have gender pronoun classes
in the military now, I mean, all of these
things that are pushing what a small minority
want on the majority of Americans.
It's too much.
I mean, the idea that we have biological boys
playing in girls sports, it is the women's
issue of our time.
Is it?
My daughter ran track in high school.
I don't even know how I would have that conversation
with her.
How are we supposed to get our girls used
to the fact that biological boys were in their
locker rooms?
Speaker 1: Okay, so she goes off the rails.
Asked to define woke, she says woke is stuff
like biological boys in girls locker rooms.
Now, she's not certainly not defining it.
She's giving examples of things she believes
are woke.
It's sort of like if I said, hey, can you
define what a fruit is?
And you go, well, you know, you've got your
banana, you've got your you've got your cantaloupe.
Right.
But what's the definition of fruit?
And we would say, oh, well, the fruit is the
seed bearing structure in a flowering plant
formed from the ovary after flowering.
Now, it's true that sometimes examples might
be more illustrative than some kind of definition,
but these are the people who say, if you can't
define woman, there's something wrong with
you.
Here was Ron DeSantis given an attempt to
given the opportunity to define work just
a few days ago.
Speaker 4: We know what work is.
It's a form of cultural Marxism.
It's about putting merit and achievement behind
identity politics.
And it's basically a war on
the truth.
And if that isn't, in fact in institutions,
it is corrupt in a lot of institutions.
So you've got to be willing to fight the war.
We've done it in Florida.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So cultural Marxism was the Santos's answer.
So a couple of different things.
The term woke has been perverted.
I don't know anyone on the left who still
uses it seriously because it's been perverted.
It now just basically means anything.
Right wingers don't like what woke meant before.
It was perverted, meant I am aware of problems
in society that might be bigger than one person.
We might call them structural problems, and
I think it would be a nice thing to fix those
problems.
That was wokeness when the term was used.
Seriously, they've now totally perverted it.
Cultural Marxism was de Santos's attempt to
define cultural Marxism as a far right anti-Semitic
conspiracy theory that blames Jewish German
academics known as the Frankfurt School, for
spreading movements like identity politics
and political correctness as some kind of
way to manipulate and undermine Western civilization
and Christian values.
That's what cultural Marxism is.
It also it uses the word Marxism, so it makes
it sound like it's somehow related to Marx.
But it's not.
It's a misnomer.
It has nothing to do with the economic and
class analysis of Karl Marx.
It also really misrepresents the ideas of
the Frankfurt Frankfurt School as well.
Like them or hate them, the Frankfurt School,
where a group of critical theorists who analyze
the role of culture in mass media and ideology
and society.
So cultural Marxism is like a post factual
dog whistle appealing to anti-Semitism and
paranoia.
That's how that's how DeSantis is defining
woke.
This is actually going to be a bigger issue
than we might think, because the longer that
they continue using woke in this way, the
more it is going to seem like an actual platform
or proposal when it's not.
It's a misunderstood talking point that they
don't even understand.
So we'll get back to it in the coming days.
Nikki Haley, swing and miss and certainly
striking out Ron DeSantis.